on talking about CD projekt Red's next
dive into the story between V and Johnny
just yet in fact we're here with the
voice and stylings of Johnny silverhand
Keanu Reeves himself welcome thank you
it's a pleasure to be here likewise well
thank Liberty introduces us to an
entirely new location in night City it's
called Dogtown it's this devastated
place it's controlled by a militia but I
think you know more about it than I do
so how would you describe it to players
night city has its own kind of
levels to it and I think dog town is
kind of going down to a darker place
um
it's dystopian
it has attention to it and
this under current of kind of violence
you know like and struggle
you know
can I swear yeah shit's gone down in
Dogtown oh I like that tagline yeah and
it's just you know I mean hopefully
it'll be fun for people to uh
to play there
it's hard to believe that there's an
underbelly to the underbelly yes that is
night city right yeah I'm a little
scared
[Music]
drawn to we're all Moths To The Flame
aren't we and there's a lot of
flame and dark time well if anyone could
take it on its V so that certainly gives
me the confidence yeah Visa Survivor
exactly oh yeah you know and we just saw
a tour of Dogtown too so we got a little
bit of that Ambiance and we can see what
the environment is like people are
getting beat up it's not good it's me
yeah it's not the friendliest place to
be you gotta you gotta be prepared for
it truly yeah but in our tour we also
hear a recording from a colonel Kurt
Hansen who's this guy because he seems
pretty dangerous too yeah that guy no
I'm sorry I can't say that my inner
Johnny came out I think that's good we
know the tone now yeah well I mean he's
ex-military military too ruthless power
hungry manipulative and Johnny doesn't
like him I could see that it's I mean
night City in general is the kind of
place that breeds that kind of character
yeah let's take a step back let's talk
about Johnny as a person instead of this
horrible person known as Colonel Kurt
Hanson I don't know about this sky but
people like Johnny and I think it's
interesting because we know him to be
opinionated he's radical we've seen that
in cyberpunk 2077 in the main campaign
but as we get to know him he's got a
sensitive side too he can actually be
quite caring oh that's what makes it so
much fun he is outspoken he is a little
grumpy and he has a right to be he's
been used he's been abused he's been
abandoned and I think that through that
kind of hardness of his outside there is
a vulnerability to him and I think
what's great about it is I I get to play
that character in so many different ways
and so the range him in his school
especially for the player you get to see
these moments in flashbacks you start to
understand he's a product of his
upbringing truly of his surrounding well
unless I get carried away I mean I mean
we can start talking about nature and
nurture
I'm sorry I keep dropping into Johnny
but uh
um yeah I like I like his anger
I like his passion I like what he stands
for he's
he's really just looking for a fair shot
and I I love that he's kind of going
through music that there's an artist
side to him and
you know I got some great speeches
there's all these moments with Johnny
where a tiny little thing you know
elicits this really fun response you can
flip him off and he double Birds you
back like I love those kind of moments
or Rock
I think another interesting lens of
looking at him as we get into Phantom
Liberty is his Dynamic with Solomon Reed
so what can you tell me about Johnny's
relationship with Idris elba's character
I think Solomon has some things in
common with Johnny in the sense of the
military the sense of being used abused
um you know it's in the title right
they're fighting for a liberty
you know Solomon's kind of trying to
reclaim his life
you know and Johnny's doing the same
thing you know it's cyberpunk 2077 so it
might start off as a revenge and it
might end his revenge but I think
sometimes he feels like he's lashing out
at the wind
you know and I think Solomon
has been living out in the continent or
desert of his life right kind of hiding
and harboring yeah but I think he also
has that kind of soft and hard side to
him as well
so as somebody who's very familiar with
Thrillers because you've started in a
few
what do you think about Phantom Liberty
makes for a good spy Thriller in
particular
the quest to understand what's going on
so and and the kind of scavenger hunt of
information
the mystery the double crossing what is
true what's fiction what can you count
on you can't count on anything that is
really kind of Amplified
well thank you so much for coming out to
another Xbox presentation you've got a
lot of fans out there in the Xbox
community so I think I can speak for all
of us and say we really appreciate you
showing up here today oh well thank you
well before I close things out I love
your help here at Keanu how do you think
Johnny would end this interview right
now
there's a lot at least
but uh Tina pleasure to meet you oh is
that how Johnny would do it yeah oh
thank you Johnny
such a pleasure to have you I thought
you were going to kick down the camera
or something so yeah you see he's
respectful you know
you're a good egg oh thank you you too
and I'll see you out there again soon
foreign